hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well there's three
basic kinds of goods on account of which
we are friends one of them is what he
calls the noble or the good in the you
know sort of elevated sense things that
we would consider we don't talk about
mobility we talk about being honorable
being stand up you know being cool is
also a term that we use in our
contemporary culture for being honorable
being or being noble beautiful you know
if we talk about moral beauty or things
like that that's also a matter of what
we're looking at here so what kind of
life do you you envision for yourself as
the life that you want do you you
envision a life where it's just
committed to accumulation of more and
more wealth or do you want to do good
things with your life
like you know I understand wanting to be
rich I'd like to be rich of myself why
did we want to be rich sometimes it's
just you know security right you have a
lot of money in the bank
a lot of storms well what do you
actually want to do with your money you
want to make people's lives better do
you want to bring people together and
introduce them to each other and have
parties where people get to know each
other and come out of it and say this is
this is such a great experience that
would be something normal according to
Aristotle if you were rich in ancient
Greece you were expected to contribute
to the public good so you would buy a
ship for the Navy or you would put on a
plane for somebody you would engage in
some sort of philanthropy like we talked
about before with you know generosity
and magnificence those are things that
are considered to be noble Aristotle
would say that there's other things that
are considered to be normal when you
stand up against fear and you make sure
that the right thing would want to be
happens even though it could be damaging
to you and you're afraid that is
something nope isn't it we tend to look
up to people like that
so sometimes we're friends of the people
on the basis of this is this type of
good and Aristotle says this this could
be an actual good you know or just good
perceive good you know do you admire
some people let me put it to you this
way have two admired some people in your
lifetime who didn't turn out to be the
genuine article
if they actually were what they seem to
be what they purport it to be then they
really were noble and then later on you
found out they were quite so quite so
good have you have any broken idols like
that I got to think of one that I never
actually really liked myself a lot of
people got behind who got into the news
quite a bit recent
last couple years think about this guy
Lance Armstrong why do people look up to
it before they found out a month ago
payments why did they associate him with
you know like good character ability and
like this story what happened to the guy
yeah I mean he was winning at one time
that's kind of a big deal then winning
it after recovering from cancer and then
after you did that
he established a foundation and I don't
even really know what his foundation did
I'm sure it had something to do with
cancer but I never liked the guy myself
I don't know what it was about every
once in awhile that was sort of
irrational yeah that's probably not as
as good as it pretends to be kind of
cynicism and I have that about him
so Kenny Hamptons I didn't get sucked in
and give any money to the guy and then
you know being able to compete and
succeed what did that show is it just
that he's a winner let people like then
he was an underdog I came back from
cancer what is it that that that we like
about people who succeeded what sort of
traits do they have to have that we
admire
yeah that's that's really a persistence
or perseverance they keep on pushing
pushing pushing and why do we like that
because that is in fact something
admirable right that's something kind of
rare to begin with and we see it and we
were like yeah I kind of like that I'd
like to be like that if I could this
goes back to that question of emulation
that we talked about to last period to
go as it turned out you know there was
only a perceived good in Lance
Armstrong's case turned out the guy was
kind of scumbag and you know not only
was he don't bring this whole time so
all of these these you know victories
should have gone to some other guy who
didn't get any accolades at all
he actually unjustly rocked somebody
else's victory because it was egotism
he lied for years and years about doping
and then gave these kind of politicians
answers well there's never been any
evidence blah blah blah blah blah and
then evidence showed up and then you
know he started talking in this legalese
instead of actually apologizing like a
real you know human being would have
done he had sort of his apology sounded
like he was a corporation and people are
like this guy turned out that he was
sort of the opposite of noble and he was
not an admirable at all he was actually
sort of at that so that wasn't perceived
good but you can still you know if you
felt something towards him some sort of
aberration that doesn't mean that your
admiration wasn't real and if you are
friends with somebody because then
you're not present walking Lance
Armstrong unless you know
although if you're friends with somebody
because you see and them real nobility
of character and they turn out not to be
that way that doesn't mean that your
feelings are invalid that just means
that the good that you base that on was
a perceived rather than an actual good
you can still have it with somebody else
if you've had that sort of relationship
with somebody you can have that with
somebody else who's actually deserving
of that relationship the second kind of
good that Aristotle talks about is
pleasure yeah I mean we've talked about
this a lot over the course of the
semester there's lots of different kinds
of pleasures ranging from you know
gourmet coffee and we shelled out a lot
something kind of kind of new and it
tastes almost like you know like flan
which is good because I like dessert too
you know the music that you have on your
your iPod or your phone that's that's
pleasant as well also there have some
sort of weird fetish about post-it notes
I suppose you know make a decorative
thing that could be pleasant some people
like drawing you know on the chalkboard
with chalk there's all sorts of things
that we find Pleasant all sorts of
things that we find unpleasant as well
you know yeah what about friends are
there some people who you're friends
with just because you enjoy their
company
yeah and that's okay
now free friendship has to be you know
the highest most complete form of
friendship where you know that person
inside and how an admirer every trait of
their character and they admire every
trend of your character and you're
spending your time you know just
reveling in your own moral goodness you
know volunteering at the soup kitchen
together go down the whole list right
they don't all have to be like that as a
matter of fact it's pretty rare that you
have friendships that are totally at
this level a lot of times we're friends
with people because we we like them we
enjoying hanging out with them what are
what are things that
make us like something if they're funny
right do we like funny people we're not
so putz of the jokes some people who'd
like to be made fun of believe it or not
and if you get a you know person who's
good at making jokes so the other person
loves being a lot of jokes I suppose
they've haven't it wasn't friendship
what else do we find Pleasant with
friends we brought hanging out what is
what is the Apple that's definitely not
doing something useful where you're
you're gonna like get tickets out of
them or or you know a job you hang out
with people because you actually enjoy
the company what do you like about your
friends company better than doing it by
yourself right
when you guys hang out with your friends
this is something to think about what
pleasant activities do you engage if
there's a talking is it watching TV
together that's that's enjoying
something right commenting on it and I'm
making jokes about the people on the TV
what else do we enjoy getting together
yeah people like drinking together
probably I do also its close things to
alright some of that can get get quite
out of hand but there's a reason why
bars exist you know if you were a
totally rational individual and didn't
need sort of the gregariousness of
company and you wouldn't actually be
totally rational either until the end
respective well let's say you you you
were just thought about yourself if you
go out to a bar how much does a drink
cost not average let's say you tap beer
around here for a pint
four bucks five bucks now think about
this rationally wouldn't it be just as
easy to sit in your dorm room or your
house or even you know so long as it's
parked in here you know keys aren't in
it in your car and go to the liquor
store or you know the grocery store and
buy yourself a 6-pack and you know maybe
like even invest in a pint glass if you
really like having a pint glass your
hand and just pour it for yourself you
know if you feel like Guinness for
example right you get a six-pack of
Guinness for this cheap as you know
$8.99 or something like that you'd be
you know saving a lot of money wouldn't
you compared to going out to the bar is
it sitting in the stool that you really
like when you can sit in a stool at home
to equip chair I mean you could go down
the list once you see where I'm going
what is it that people like about going
to bars other people company hanging out
and it doesn't even have to be like
engaging in you know deep conversations
they can just be sitting next to
somebody else quietly who you know do
you guys remember it's a very long time
you remember that show Cheers you know
the song was kind of famous everybody
knows your name
they're always glad you came that is a
set of friendships that are based on
pleasure sexual relationships are
hopefully matters of pleasure you know
when you sleep with somebody if you're
both having a good time you're actually
enjoying each other right so there's
lots of ways it could be a companionship
it could be engaging in sports together
it could be you know sexual or romantic
relationships it could be working on
models together there's all sorts of
things that people do that are matters
of the pleasant and you know these are
not necessarily life-changing events you
know every time that you go out to the
bar or you
go to the coffee shop with your friend
you're not like suddenly becoming this
noble human being and knowing your
friend inside and out for who they are
are you okay that if your life is like
that you can you need to start writing
it down because that would make a great
movie or TV show applause so pleasure is
is is something that's legitimate the
third kind of friendship there is little
talks about is based on the useful good
what we do sometimes called a profitable
the useful and this is where you're
friends with somebody not on the basis
of who they are and you know actually
loving them for who they are nor because
you actually enjoy their company or
getting something pleasant from them but
because you're getting something else
from them yeah and we might be tempted
to say well you're not really friends
with that person at all you're only
apparently friends because you're you're
using them but let's think for a moment
of all the sort of things that people do
in fact who are friendly towards each
other at least for a while do in fact
engage with each other to get have you
ever been friends with somebody so that
they could help you out of school that
would be this kind of example right what
else a lot of times rich kids have lots
of friends don't they why exactly that's
you know they'll they'll have the
parties they'll take people skiing
they'll you know pay for the meals pay
for the drinks now if those kids put
doing that how long would the
relationship go on it would it would
probably wouldn't go on you know a lot
of cases unless you actually like the
person because they're doing it more you
like them from their own sake how else
do people use each other
think about business contacts you guys
need business contacts
don't you how many of you've done
internships so far well they feel maybe
you're gonna do an internship this
summer or before you graduate at least
everybody I hope so
when you get involved with people
through the internships are you going to
keep their contact information you
better and you better every once in a
while say hey I'm still alive don't
forget about me and you're doing that
because they are a useful contact right
they may help you to get a job or they
may hook you up with somebody else
who can hook you up with a job or a
business opportunity for an opportunity
for study or who knows what else that's
important that's it that's a vital part
of life
Aristotle recognizes that he sees that
beyonce is good it's just not the same
kind of good as these girls what else do
we use each other for oh that's a good
one
yeah information there are some people
who you might be friends with because
you supply them with certain information
and they supply you with certain
information
I suppose the studying with a classmate
would be sort of an apprenticeship than
that but there will be yeah I know that
I have a friend for example who I'm
friends with they actually through these
other reasons but I also enjoy our
conversations because I get a lot of
useful information about what's going on
with artificial intelligence and how to
apply computing to parsing language
these are these are things that I'm
interested in and I have other friends
that I'm in contact with in part because
they stay on top of other things that
I'm interested in and you probably have
things like like that as well right
you know conceivably you could be
friends with somebody and stay friends
with them because they've know what's
with everybody in your whole social
circle that's like your high school
circles and you find that information
useful right
Aristotle is not saying that any of
these are death as a matter of fact all
of these are good but there is a order
this is the best this is better this is
merely good and if you have to sacrifice
one to the other you would probably want
to sacrifice this to this or this to
this the other way around
now what else can we say about these
different kinds of friendship well which
friendships are going to be the most
lasting yeah
yeah more superficial I mean you know if
somebody your friends are somebody
because they can actually get you a job
we tend to look at that as being
superficial but jobs are important that
you know you're gonna provide for your
family but yeah you're right there's
there's a greater know there's also
something else with this ham friendship
we our friends with the person we feel
the way that we do towards them we feel
that goodwill for exam we love them in
some sense for their own stake for who
they are in these cases we love them for
what it is that they can give us we're
not really loving them for for who they
are in their their personality there are
aspects of their personality when it
comes to the pleasure thing like if
somebody's a good Joker or you like the
fact that they always have the right now
I'm here something along those lines dad
is more rooted in their personality than
just usefulness
you have usefulness is like being at the
right place at the right time but it's
not yet really liking the person before
their own sake so that that's a key
element these friendships tend to be
more stable than these friendships as
well in part because you know if you
like somebody for who they are that that
should stay more or less the same if it
turns out that you were wrong about it
let's say you actually were friends with
Lance Armstrong and he had you fooled
you and you found out no he was doping
all
and he actually used you to like help
tell his story you feel betrayed
wouldn't you and that that friendship
that you thought was based on who the
person really wanted to break up and a
lot of times we think when we're
involved in romantic relationships that
were actually having this kind of
relationship whatever reality we're
having this kind of relationship these
kind of relationships break up pretty
easily because as soon as somebody stops
being pleasant then the reason for the
friendship is going away you might
actually be you know a nice person and
saying well maybe it'll come back or you
know they were good to me at one time so
I should stay friends with them but
you'll find it in life that unless you
are a sink
that's not very effective that a lot of
times once pleasure goes away the
friendship will break up usefulness is
even less stable why because if you form
a friendship on the basis of usefulness
to each other as soon as that usefulness
goes away you're done
so think about business associates you
know who go out to lunch together do
they need to go out to lunch together
after all of their possible business
deals are done and they're no longer of
any use to each other if they don't
already like each other because they
enjoy each other's company
or really like the person who who they
are are they going to keep going to
lunch together
no and Arizona says that's okay that's
that kind of friendship now notice one
other thing that he says to ivenna we'll
talk a little bit more about friendships
facility if you have this kind of
friendship you also have this kind of
traction our people who are are pleasant
for each other who give each other
pleasure are they also useful to the
other person you like luckier don't you
that person is therefore useful
are they and very often we will in fact
extend ourselves and do favors for
people who we enjoy you know hanging out
with being at the same company we're
more likely to do that than somebody off
the street think about here that you'd
be an example it's usually a bad idea to
lend friends money there you guys
learned this lesson yeah we recognize
facial recognition zuv that it's a bad
idea because then you're placing this
debtor-creditor relationship which is a
little bit different and it's no fun to
have to ask your friends for the money
that they know if they're a good person
they'll pay you back right away but a
lot of times you find out what the
people aren't good people when you loan
the money and then they don't pay it
back you're better off and not just
money to books also if you're gonna give
some if you're gonna give a friend
something just give it to them and then
you know don't worry about whether
you're gonna get back because then it's
a lot less hassle but if you find
somebody pleasant if you enjoy their
company are you more likely to do
something like that
are you are you more likely to give them
along when they need it
are you more likely to give them a gift
when it would help them out yeah because
you already feel good towards them right
so the pleasant friendship includes the
useful friendship very small size and
what about this this highest law of
attraction where you you know the person
is you like the kind of person that they
are remember you also share common
desires share joys and sorrows do
activities together are they going to be
pleasant for you or is this sort of like
I'll put up with the sacrifice for the
sake of the noble good I you know I have
to be friends with this person because
I'm really a good person I don't like
hanging out with them they irritate me I
get no pleasure in there
company but yet I'm going to spend lots
of time with them and commiserate with
them because there's such a good person
does that make sense
no I mean you if you were like a server
without you and I suppose you could do
that sort of thing but not too many
people are know generally if you like
the other person's character you would
enjoy being with them that's how you can
tell that you have good character that
you actually like being with other
people who have a good character they
don't make you feel bad because you look
at them and you're like yeah they're
pretty good people I'm not a good person
I feel kind of ashamed they don't they
don't make you feel like that they
actually make you feel kinda happy it's
enjoyable to be with them and they
probably should also be willing to share
with you the things that are not all
about good character they they play you
know pickup games with you they hang out
with you we have they eat with you those
sorts of things
what about usefulness our friends who
have good character are going to also be
useful for each other we will they
extend themselves to open doors for
somebody who they they also recognized
to have a good character if they don't
there's something really wrong with them
and they don't actually have a good
character part of what it means to have
a good character is to try to promote
other people's good isn't it and if I
have a good character and you have a
good character and I can write a good
letter of recommendation for you you
think I would actually say well we only
have this kind of relationship it's all
about your moral mobility and my moral
mobility I'm not going to actually do
anything useful for you you look at me
like I was nuts wouldn't you wait a
second if you actually like me you think
I'm a good person what you're not going
to write a letter of recommendation for
me or make a contact for me I'm the
person you should actually be doing that
for the most and then actually when I
write letters of recommendation I tend
to put in quite a few things about the
person's character if I do know anything
about their character you know like
traits like perseverance particularly
like that it makes sense that this would
actually encompass all of these other
things now here's here's sort of a
little capstone question to bring this
all together can a bad person be a good
friend yeah anything senses not just a
morally neutral person a person who may
actually has vices well you're not gonna
like them for their character right so
they're definitely not going to have
this kind of thing but what about
pleasure or usefulness
yes there are some things that they
could have these but a bad person is
going to be less reliable they they may
actually not be able to give you
pleasure then think about this can you
have a good sexual relationship with
somebody who's a fundamentally bad
person it can happen but you'd better
really watch everything outside of the
bedroom so they don't steal your wallet
or you know sleep with your friends or
that ounce you to the government or
picking up the Concord bad things that
somebody might be prone to do take all
your credit cards back into your phone
you know they're less likely to be
really pleasant or to remain close and
you've got to watch them all the time
what about usefulness bad person they're
only going to be interested in
you in so far as you can give that one
of these two things and if you put being
useful to them there it would be useful
to you really really quick as a matter
of fact because they're a bad person
they may in fact quit being useful to
you long before you quit being useful to
them they tend to be the kind of people
that we call Free Riders have you heard
about Vivier that's turned before the
free rider problem if most people are
generally following the rules and being
good you'll have some people to say well
if I do something bad it's not going to
you know knock the whole system down
so I'll do it and then all will get away
with it came from riding the subway it
was look at the honor system you know no
not everybody would be checked all the
time some people would ride for free we
have used to actually do this in Germany
we call it the the freiburg if you've
got you know as opposed to that move on
if you've got clot there was a fun but
odds are you're probably not going to
get caught so I knew people would do it
all trial those people would not be good
friends because somebody is going to do
that do you want to have a relationship
with them that's based solely on
usefulness that you don't have like some
sort of contract to enforce probably not
so the character of the person matters
not only for the high end but also